verkohlt von den flammen ausgetrocknet
von der hitze wir sind unterwegs im
norden von kalifornien in sankt helena
treffen wir alexandria die brandgefahr
hier jetzt gerade enorm die angst vor
dem feuer ein ständiger begleiter wir
machen uns die ganze zeit sorgen ob wir
es durch diese feuer saison schaffen
die dauert immer länger die feier zeit
geht mittlerweile von mai bis oktober
oder november
es hört erst auf wenn es regnet
dass ihr haus noch steht alles andere
als selbstverständlich
der verheerende feuer sommer im
vergangenen jahr war hier ganz besonders
heftig alarm oft mitten in der nacht
da hinten stand damals noch das haus von
nachbarn
sie haben geschlafen ich habe gegen ihre
tür gehämmert
sie sind dann zu uns ins auto und wir
sind losgefahren alexandria ist
sozialarbeiterin verdient das geld für
die familie ihr mann auf jobsuche will
nicht vor die kamera
mit ihren kindern julia und sophie
mussten sie fünf monate im hotel
ausharren nach der feuernacht die feier
schäden waren groß der schuldenberg ist
es noch die versicherung zahlt nur einen
teil
alle zäune waren abgebrannt die veranda
der garten fast alles bis auf das haus
erst hatte extreme brandflecken es war
knapp aber die feuerwehr hat in unserem
garten gegen die flammen gekämpft
der mut der feuerwehrleute und glück mit
dem wind haben das zuhause von
alexandria gerettet doch der ausblick
erinnert sie jeden tag an die
verheerenden flammen mehrere
nachbarhäuser sind komplett abgebrannt
und es brennt immer weiter immer früher
immer länger im aktuellen hitze sommer
gab es schon etwa 700 brände mehr als im
vergangenen jahr zu dieser zeit drei
monate länger als noch in den 70er
jahren dauert die feuer saison
mittlerweile so experten der boden
knochentrocken und was ist mit dem
wasser mit den stauseen wir fahren zum
label nördlich von sacramento am
höchsten staudamm der usa 30 cm sinkt
der wasserspiegel hier jeden tag geht
das so weiter müssten angeschlossene
kraftwerke im august abgeschaltet werden
stromausfälle drohen für zehntausende
schon jetzt dramatisch all das für die
pharma die sind verabredet mit john
booth die ranch hat er übernommen von
seinen eltern 7 100 milchkühe gibt es
hier normalerweise fast 100 musste john
in den vergangenen sechs wochen
verkaufen er hat keine andere wahl sagt
er uns jetzt müssen wir entscheidungen
treffen
wir behalten die besten tiere die
gesunden nach den anderen die etwa zu
klein sind überlegen wir welche wir
verkaufen
es gibt viel zu wenig weidegras weil es
viel zu wenig regnet wir müssen mehr
futter einkaufen
unser heute kommt dann aus regionen wie
oracle oder nevada
aber diese regionen sind auch
ausgetrocknet für john und viele andere
gelten strikte wasser regeln sie müssen
ihren verbrauch reduzieren um 40 prozent
wenige minuten von der ranch entfernt
der russian river einfluss jetzt zum
teil nur noch zentimeter tief ein
bundesstaat trocknet aus lebensadern die
über die jahre immer schwächer werden in
einer region die viel wasser braucht
etwa für das produkt von hier wein aus
sonoma county catherine ist seit 23
jahren im geschäft stolz etwa auf ihren
rosé oder ihren pinot noir
[Musik]
sie spart wasser wo immer es geht hat
eine aufbereitungsanlage mit hilfe von
bakterien wird das abwasser des weinguts
hier gereinigt kann wieder verwendet
werden
ich habe das system seit 2009 damals war
das sehr ungewöhnlich trocken heiß ja
manchmal gefährlich war es hier schon
immer im sommer erzählt uns grizzly
jetzt aber werde es immer schwieriger
[Musik]
2020 hatten wir verheerende brände das
war schrecklich viele trauben konnten
wir nicht mehr verwenden
der rauch hat sie zerstört das hat
natürlich enorme folgen wirtschaftliche
folgen
ich konnte nur halb so viel wein
verkaufen wie geplant
der sommer 2020 in kalifornien ein
entfernung mit schrecklichen rekorden
mehr als 30 tote tausende häuser enorm
viel land zerstört die tödlichen feuer
die gefährliche dürre hauptgründe für
sie kalifornien zu verlassen
die deutsche kinderbuchautorin cornelia
funke lebt seit 17 jahren in amerika im
september ist schluss es geht zurück
nach europa ich möchte nicht auf die
dauer mit den feuern leben die werden
jetzt immer öfter kommt so viel tote
bäume inzwischen in den wäldern gibt und
auch viel zu wenige bäume die für den
regen ja letztlich sorgen wir treffen
cornelia funke in ihrem haus in malibu
bei los angeles traumhaft schön großer
reichtum große pools mit viel wasser die
probleme aber werden größer
es gab nie heißer als 28 grad
in dem ersten jahr es gab immer regen im
winter
es war einfach so unter meiner
assistentin ist geboren hier die kann
überhaupt nicht glauben wie es sich
verändert hat
verändert verschlechtert abschied also
aus malibu
auch die familie von alexandria in sankt
helena will weg aus den
waldbrandgebieten aktuell aber könne sie
sich einen umzug ganz einfach nicht
leisten mensch und natur haben schwer zu
kämpfen mit feuer und dürre in
kalifornien